let's talk about what could be the most
explosive issue of this campaign if the
mass media would get ahold of and do
something about it but they're covering
it up and that is the you were talking
about the government involvement in
drugs
there have been government
investigations there have been private
investigations and we've interviewed a
lot of people protects CIA people who
have talked about the CIA involvement
and drug operations for many decades
it's public knowledge so once again the
media are not saying thing about it that
Oliver North and his people involved
with the Contras have been running drug
operations cocaine primarily bringing it
back into the United States and there
are other investigations which show that
George Bush's office Donald Gregg
particularly in the people he was
working with have been supervising an
enormous drug operation which once again
was bringing sending illegal arms or
down to the contours and elsewhere and
bringing cocaine and other types of
drugs back into the United States but
neither the Democrats aren't talking
about this now are the libertarians
talking about this and do they put this
into the framework of the drug law
situation that you're talking about we
talk about a whole lot of course we
always have the trouble of getting the
attention that we think it deserves
there have been a few Democrats have
talked about sort of carries office I
heard some work he's done in live the
investigation right and I think he's on
to something and I think we've gotten
some other information too of course
that George or the CIA has given the
Noriega over the years $200,000 a year
your yet and they kept feeding him money
even when Bush was a head of the CIA I
think George Bush is deep into it well
over the his head somebody asked me once
of if I thought George Bush knew about
as much what's going on as Ronald Reagan
I think George Bush knew a lot more
about what was having the CIA because I
think Reagan was probably more remove
from that I mean just by his own
personality and maybe his age or
something but I think George Bush
through his office and through and
through the fact that he was a member of
this you know head of the CIA I think he
was very very close to it he knows
exactly what was happening and I believe
the rule that once the CIA member always
a CIA member and I think it's awful
interesting can you imagine it would
alarm a few of us in this country of all
of a sudden we knew that the leader in
the Soviet Union would be the head KGB
agent here we take our head CIA agent
and put them you know potentially in the
head of our entire country unfortunately
I wish that we could get this
information out and I continue to talk
about it but I sadly believe that there
will be very little said which means
that the Democrat aren't doing it that
means they're involved here involved off
and I don't think there's any doubt
about it I mean it was even some of it
got reported in the iran-contra scandals
we did know that there were drugs being
drugs involved and and they were selling
drugs back and forth I think that might
be the number one reason for the drug
laws I mean they use and play on the
good people of America to support them
but I think the number one reason is not
not to have high prices for some two-bit
drug dealer as much as to raise the
funds necessary to for governments to do
illegal things whether it's some
terrorist government someplace or
whether it's our own CIA to fund
programs that they can't get Congress to
fund
I think it's tragic and the sooner we
get rid of the drug laws the sooner this
would end